this is what dreams are made of big year
for you and it's so funny because last
year you hinted that Lizzie McGuire
might be coming back everything like no
it's too soon I feel like you manifested
it that night she was so important to
girls at an important time in their life
and if she could be important to them
again at this age like I think that
would be amazing it's a dream come true
yeah we started filming and it was a
long time coming like I mean you know
since last year and the conversation was
like just starting to happen so it's
crazy I mean filming in LA when I'm so
excited to have a job in LA and to you
know we were having a lot of fun and
it's it just feels very surreal the
family back the family back what are the
chances and what would it mean if Gordo
and Miranda were to be thrown back in
the mix like what would you like to see
them do if that were to happen again I
cannot get in trouble tonight so I'm
just gonna keep my mouth shut and you
guys are gonna have to watch and follow
our journey what about this question my
favorite thing growing up and watching
Lizzie was that she was a little bit
awkward and kind of going through some
real struggles now that she's in her 30s
what kind of struggles do we see her go
through can you answer that yeah I think
that was part of the draw for me of
coming back was like the struggles that
I feel of being a 30 year old and
obviously we're in very different places
I'm a mother I'm in a serious
relationship and she has a lot of those
things she has gained a lot of
confidence and she has a really cool
career and you know she's still I think
she's still gonna be faced with
challenging things we're in middle
school those challenging things seemed
funny and simple but relatable at the
time and I think now in your 30s it's
gonna be the same way but it's like
slightly heavier slightly bigger things
to deal with like she doesn't have kids
yet and she you know she there's some
surprises in the first episode animated
Lizzie does she have an updated look
she's gonna she's gonna stay the same
yeah which i think is is the right thing
to do right it's like that pink top it's
so iconic and like platform flip-flops
yeah those like rocket dog flip-flops I
don't know if anyone knows those but
yeah she has an epic return and I'm I'm
so excited for everyone to I think she's
really gonna be a lot of the comic
relief in the show yeah did you see that
Liz o is hoping for a cameo
I mean we're hoping to have her talk to
her about this um ask out well the ask
was out like via Twitter when she was
like yeah I tweeted I tweeted back to
her when I saw her excitement by the way
I'm never on Twitter so I was like how
do i navigate this thing but yeah I mean
we I think that would be a dream and
she's obviously the coolest so high
chance that Lizzy's engaged to Ethan now
I was kind of hoping that Lizzy would
help out this time I love the way events
of my name lyzzie lyzzie lyzzie lyzzie
lyzzie lyzzie lyzzie lyzzie no she's not
currently engaged to Ethan Kraft someone
else like a new a new person like in his
place well you said that Lizzy's engaged
she I have no idea what you're talking
about
I'm so bad at playing Kawai I'm like an
open book it sucks like people like I'm
not helping cuz I'm also so excited
about it that I directing digging at me
and yeah hard to keep it the secret um
you know what it's yes it is because I'm
excited about it too I I'm I'm a fan and
it's such a big part of me and I feel
like we want to give everybody what they
came for but we also want to have an
updated show that stands apart from that
and it's really a different it's
familiar but it's different and we were
really striving for that you know
Matthew koma called you his wife on
Instagram and everyone was like are they
secretly married can you set the record
straight
yes no we are not secretly married but
we are basically married so you know
sometimes sometimes those little things
slip out are you wedding planning right
now I'm not wedding planning right now
we have we have a lot going on and we're
really excited and we're like torn
between are we just gonna go like to the
chapel and I don't know like do it are
we going to you know have a little more
thought put into it did you elope um I
think our families would kill us yeah
you know yeah and we want the kids to be
involved yeah so it's we need like he's
getting ready to leave for tour like I
don't know do it that guy again I'm
shooting it's crazy shows yeah dogs it's
it's a lot right now you were here last
year the first annual year you're here
again you're hosting tonight what is it
that keeps you so involved with lovely
Oh Sasha the founder of love leo has
become a really good friend of mine and
Sarah who works with her who's Michelle
Marie epr and they work tirelessly and
that this stuff if you just merely
follow love leo rescue on instagram i
mean it's it's like tears every day like
the work that they do is so amazing I'm
so inspired by them I rescue two of my
pups from love leo who you know I don't
know what we would do without them and
they this event so many people come out
for it we've raised a lot of money and
Sasha is just an angel so you know I I
would never not show up unless I
physically couldn't cuz your fans will
kill me if I don't ask you new music
[Music]
no new music time for that right now I
don't I don't have time for new music
right now and I always feel like I'm
letting every like I don't know a
certain small group of people who still
care about my music Java love your voice
you're so sweet
maybe I don't know I never can say no
because they could happen
[Music]